are you sick of all the fees and the
hassle of having a checking account at a
big bank check out our sponsor current
using the link below I'll tell you more
about them at the end of the video so
we've been tracking very closely this
extraordinarily concerning authoritarian
slide by Donald Trump where he is now
asserting to have absolute power over
governors and over what governors tell
businesses and schools within their
states to do the context is all
reopening the economy from coronavirus
and Donald Trump signaling yesterday
during his press briefing that there is
somewhere between 20 and 29 states that
he believes very soon
even before potentially the April 30th a
social distancing deadline may be able
to start to open up there are states
that have already said we're not going
to listen to Trump we're going to do
what our public health officials say and
Donald Trump has now asserted multiple
times that he has absolute authority
over the states here's one example from
Monday's press briefing what you're
trying no not at all let me just a very
simple I'm gonna put it very simply the
President of the United States has the
authority to do what the president has
the authority to do which is very
powerful the president of the United
States calls the shots if we weren't
here for the states you would have had a
problem in this country like you've
never seen before we were here to back
them up and we back and we've more than
backed them up we did a job that nobody
ever thought was possible it's a
decision for the President of the United
States now with that being said we're
going to work with the states because
it's very important you have local
governments there pinpoint it it's
really you talk about it's a like a
microchip they're pinpointed we have
local government that hopefully will do
a good job and if they don't do a good
job I'd step in so fast but no they
can't do anything without the approval
of the President here's another specific
question from another reporter and Trump
is just not backing down he wants to be
the authoritarian he also wants to avoid
responsibility when things go wrong but
he wants to be the authoritarian take a
look
of your authority these of the
governor's just be very specific for
instance if a governor issued a state
home when you say my authority the
president's authority not mine because
it's not me this is when somebody's the
president of the United States the
authority is total and that's so it's
got to be your authority speaks total
there you have a couple of bands of
excuse me excuse me
you have a couple you have a couple of
bands of Democrat governors but they
will agree to it they will agree to her
but the authority of the President of
the United States having to do with the
subject we're talking about his total
and then lastly here's CNN's Katelyn
Collins pressing him and asking has has
where did you get this idea who told you
that you have this absolute authority
over governors and has any governor said
they agree that you have this authority
we're going to write up papers on this
it's not going to be necessary because
the governor's need us one way or the
other
because ultimately it comes with a
federal government that being said we're
getting along very well with the
governor's and I feel very certain that
there won't be a problem Trump obviously
not really giving an answer so yesterday
I told you it's not even clear that a
governor can force a business to open
like can Charlie Baker here in
Massachusetts go to my favorite sushi
and Indian food restaurants and say you
have to open I don't think that he can
so the idea that the president can force
the governor's to make businesses do
those things is a joke but now that
we've had another 24 hours the
constitutional law experts have weighed
in and not only does Trump lack the
powers he claims to have the
Constitution is actually very clear that
he can't do what he says he is able to
do and both Republicans and Democrats
who are thinking about this clearly seem
to be on the same page here's Republican
congresswoman Liz Cheney the daughter of
the diabolical former Vice President
Dick Cheney she tweeted that quote the
federal government does not have
absolute power the powers not delegated
to the United States by the Constitution
nor prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the States respectively or
to the people that's the 10th amendment
to the Constitution now Trump frequently
will mention federalism when he talks
about why he has this absolute power
he'll say this often during the White
House coronavirus press briefings and he
pretends to understand what it means but
federalism and practice tells us the
president can tell state governors what
to do other than in the very specific
areas outlined in the Constitution now
it is true that in times of emergency
presidents have tried to figure out how
to boss governor's around but they
failed to do it
during the Korean War Harry Truman
declared a national emergency seized
private steel mills tried to preempt
preempt steel workers from striking
argued you know the mills are essential
to national defense and the Supreme
Court actually decided the other way in
a case called Youngstown its Youngstown
V I forget the name of it but it's
Youngstown something so this has been
tested and it's not gone the federal
government's way now there's another
important element Trump never shut the
country down he just didn't do it how
can Trump reopen something he didn't
close in the first place whether Trump
could shut down the country by directing
governor's to do it is question one
answer is it doesn't seem that he can do
it but in practice Trump never shut down
states governor's made decisions at
different points in time and it's up to
governor's to decide to reopen what we
have is a wannabe dictator on our hands
and sadly when the Senate prejudged
Trump's impeachment and decided were
acquitting him before the trial even
started
they actually reinforced the notion that
Trump can do anything and Trump has said
article 2 of the Constitution says I can
do whatever I want Trump may well
believe this he hasn't actually
demonstrated it legally but in practice
what consequences have there been you
know when Trump Trump's not supposed to
violate the emoluments clause but he did
it and there haven't been consequences
Trump has done it with no consequences
the entire presidency and this is why
it's so important to remove this clown
in November the law is not on Trump's
side here and in many other cases the
Constitution is not on Trump's side here
and in many other cases but he's been
getting away with whatever he wants for
more than three years at this point and
there have been no repercussions other
than a few of his former friends having
to go to prison for a few years he has
done damage as a result of being
essentially immune to consequences and
he's just going to keep doing it until
we remove him if we do so in November
we'll talk a little later about Bernie's
recent comments about this former
President Obama's recent comments about
it but
in the meantime let me know where you
fall on this issue of Trump versus the
governor's on who has the right the
power the authority that Trump claims to
have I think it's pretty clear
constitutional experts seem to think
it's very clear I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman let me know what you think we
often talk about the many different ways
that big banks take advantage of their
customers and one of our sponsors today
is current which is an online bank for
those of us who were sick of dealing
with all of the fees and the nonsense
from the big banks I use current myself
if you're watching this on YouTube
here's my actual current debit card that
I'm holding up no minimum balance they
have 24/7 support no overdraft fees up
to $100 and it won't get declined no ATM
fees you can use over fifty five
thousand ATMs nationwide and unlike
other banks you receive your direct
deposits instantly which means you'll
get paid by your employer up to two days
sooner you can deposit checks instantly
using your camera phone and unlike other
banks current instantly refunds the hold
on your card from pumping gas you can
pause your debit card instantly also
really useful in many situations there
are just so many different advantages to
ditching the big banks and instead use a
bank that puts their members first it
takes two minutes to sign up they'll
immediately ship you your debit card for
free go ahead and get started by
clicking the link down below the video